[music]
>> The reason we quote
for example, Surah An'am
chapter number six
the cattle.
Surah Baqarah
chapter number two
the cow.
So that now you know Baqarah means cow.
In Hindi, Baqarah we say for goat,
Baqarah.
Sometimes the words are similar but may
have a different meaning.
We say Bakr-id, we slaughter the goat.
But Baqarah in Arabic means cow.
So Fahm is different. In Fahm you may
think yes will become no and no will
become yes.
For example, Fitna. I know Fitna in Urdu
means
it's a Fitna means
Fitna means
in Urdu?
Fitna means?
The Indians.
What is the meaning of Fitna?
Fitna means?
Not corruption.
Fitna means more of a
adversity. Problematic person.
Fitna karta hai. But in Arabic, Fitna
means a trial.
So Quran says your wife is a trial for
you. So in Urdu you will think wife is a
Fitna means she is a problem for me.
Yes, the Quran says she can be an enemy.
So Fahm is very dangerous.
It's sometimes good for Fahm.
So knowing Arabic as a language is very
important for a Dai.
Unfortunately, I don't know as a
language Fahm I've got.
Therefore, I take the help of the
translations
to be safe rather than to be sorry.
So in references
Surah Baqarah
chapter number two, the cow.
This is how you should memorize right
from
Surah Fatiha chapter number one to Surah
Nas
chapter number 114, the mankind.
Now this was the homework given to you
more than two weeks ago.
And two weeks to memorize 114
is very easy, right or wrong?
114 divide by
14, what's the answer? Who's good in
maths here?
114 divide by 14, what is the answer?
Yeah, very slow.
114 divide by 14
eight, somewhere close to eight.
See why?
Alhamdulillah, I was good in maths.
I yet consider myself to be good in
maths.
There are something keys. I in school
knew that 114 divide by seven
give you 16.
14 will give you
half, eight. I don't have a calculator
with me. I'm doing my calculation.
I didn't know I'm going to use this as
an example. While I'm doing the example,
I'm calculating in my mind. 114 I knew
in school 114 divide by 15 comes to
approximate seven and a half. Now add
one more so it comes close to eight. And
you calculate the answer will be right.
This is all
going in the mind.
No mapping.
Ask a question.
He can't reply. You reply. Who was good
in maths in school? Raise your hand.
Who was good in maths?
No one.
I have done my school 1982. I left
school.
18 plus another 16.
18 plus 16?
Very slow.
34 see if you fast.
Now that I won't ask this question. So
all this will come inshallah by time.
Now I'm asking you the question that
when only thing we asked you is about
somewhere close to eight Surahs in a
day.
Maximum nine.
And counting these two days, it become
less than eight.
At least about
maybe 17 18 days before. No, much more
than that. If you count, maybe three
weeks before now. Three weeks ago. When
you give them homework?
In December, no?
First of that.
First second, okay.
17 days.
Now how many of you
know all the 114
Surah names
with meanings
very well? Raise your hand.
Arsh.
Huh?
Not very well. Why?
It was in his temporary memory, did not
put in the permanent memory.
Huh?
He's a student of Islamic International
School
who is ought to know.
If he doesn't know
who's to blame? The school? Who's to
blame, brother Arsh?
Give the microphone to him.
Of course, me.
He put in his temporary memory and he
performed well.
He performed well, no?
He was the instructor. I wasn't the
instructor.
But again, if someone has excelled
and he doesn't brush up, for him to come
back to the excellence is a small
percentage of time required than as
compared to the
new person. Why? You know when you have
cookies, you know cookies are put into
the computer?
When you go to that same site it
retrieves back from the
the refresh it comes back. Computer
mind. Human being is a computer.
Now all these examples what I gave, I
did not give the example in the last
training program. Because at that time
where was the cookies and where was the
internet? Just started.
In 1999.
Technique is the same. Examples are
different.
I did not know
before I came on the stage I'm going to
give this example. This is all
experience.
Therefore, the longer I take to give a
training program, it becomes longer and
the examples keep on improving. Every
time
I come on the stage and handle question
and session, I feel alhamdulillah Allah
has helped me, my answer has improved.
That's the reason every week I used to
take in Bombay open question and
session. The more you practice, the more
you excel. Now once this example I like
I did not know I'm going to give, I put
it in the permanent memory.
Now next time when I have to give
reference I'll use the reference of
cookies. I did not know I'm going to use
this type of example.
When someone asked me a question I never
heard of it before, I give an answer I
like it, I put it in the permanent
memory.
Now Arsh to get back
would be easier
than a person who's doing it for the
first time.
Because he had put it in his memory.
He did not practice so it went back
from compression to non-compressed.
But the cookies he had there
the cookies he had there.
So if he has to refresh
it's easier.
But again, he has to struggle, strive,
but lesser than you.
So actually he had an advantage.
But
people may say
I have done the training in school. Now
why should I waste 33 days here?
Yes.
My son did the training.
Yes, Arsh did the training.
Many students want to come here. I
selected only two.
Because that was training done in '99.
He didn't do under me. He saw my video
tape.
And did with the instructor of the
school. Good, alhamdulillah.
Even the 10% benefit took them far away.
But now
it's with experience
adding more power.
That time what the gigabyte was, if you
say that my computer had
MB it was good. Now no GB. In my office
everything is in TB.
Everything.
The minimum any of my editing computer
has is minimum 16 TB. That is being
outdated now.
32 TB each computer.
Now anyone who knows what's a TB, what's
a terabyte?
You will get shocked. No, that's not
full. We have 50 computers all put
together require 32 terabytes. I have
only one computer require 32 terabytes.
Power.
That's the reason.
You know my son, he is in Jamia Talim
and he was doing a diploma and he wasn't
getting leave for 45 days.
I said okay, not getting leave it's from
Allah, what can you do? So my friend
said no, no, no.
Doing this course is more important than
even one year, even if he doesn't get
the diploma.
So he forced me to speak to a minister
who put pressure and he got the leave.
But they said if you don't come for two
months you don't get the diploma. No
problem.
This course may not be done again.
Doing it live has a different impact.
The knowledge you get not only will
improve you as a Dai, will improve in
management skills and other things.
So person should realize
that where to go for what.
To identify an expert is also an art.
If you can't identify an expert and go
to the wrong person and waste your time,
that's also a waste of time.
So this reference is nothing but number
one help of Allah, number two practice,
struggling, striving.
Do it now. Now is the time. You have
left your baggage at home.
Except the clothes you have got here.
Baggage has two meanings.
No, now I got my baggage.
Yeah, that baggage you got is the
clothes. But the other problems?
Therefore, it's preferable for people to
come out and do studies here. People who
are staying here to be disturbed by the
parent, by the family, by the this. Here
you are in your room, okay? Once in a
while you phone and hello, how are you?
Salaam alaikum. Salaam.
That's for normal human being. For me,
wherever I travel, my baggage is with
me. Because we have so much to do.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allahu
Allahu